quel visage pour coignières dans quinze
ans c'est à cette question que doit
répondre le plan local d'urbanisme
une nouveauté pour la commune qui a
intégré l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines
l'an passé une nouvelle réunion
d'information était organisée sur ce
sujet hier soir au théâtre
alphonse daudet le maire et son équipe
municipale ont présenté les grandes
orientations de ce document entre
préservation du cadre de vie et
nouvelles constructions reportage à quoi
ressemblera coigné en 2030 comment
rendre complémentaires le volet rural et
commercial de la ville
près d'une centaine de personnes étaient
présentes pour cette réunion publique et
écouter le maire a exposé ses
propositions pour l'aménagement et le
développement durable de la commune est
d'ici 15 ans coignières un peu plus de
4300 habitants devrait voir sa
population augmenter de 28%
nous devons aussi construire des
logements sur coignières 1 c'est une une
nécessité pour que coignières vivent
également nous avons des secteurs
commerciaux intéressant nous avons un
secteur industriel est également
intéressant mais il nous faut également
construire des logements parce qu'il
nous faut accueillir les personnes qui
ont un parcours résidentiel et qui
veulent rester sur panne hier pour
préserver son image de village à la
campagne
la majorité a détaillé aux habitants
quatre grandes orientations et une
vingtaine de points parmi ceux ci la
diversification de l'offre de logement
le renforcement de l'attractivité
commerciale ou encore comme attrape
récemment l'enfouissement de la
nationale 10 ce qui est important là
entre autres c'est sûr secret à l'ab de
la nationale 10
cette histoire d'enfouissement qui était
dans les cartons mais dont on pense
maintenant que ce serait quand même
quelque chose qui soit acté quoi je
trouve c'est une bonne démarche surtout
des questions sur le l'augmentation du
nombre de logements du fait que one year
est resté en outre est stable depuis 40
ans et donc aussi sur le l'accessibilité
qui était intéressante aussi une
nouvelle réunion publique est prévue le
5 juillet prochain l'approbation du pmu
est prévu quand elle pour juin 2018